[Music]
i don't understand i mean this sincerely
how you're so funny you're such a great
uh rapper yeah and here you are killing
it oh man
this is what i do man i'm just i'll just
be me man
weed man
no stage right
he's good
a comfortable man um
here's a question
i'm rapping along to your song and you
drop the n-word yeah should i pause no
no
no just just keep keep going yeah keep
going
until i actually have a part at my show
where i have this song where i say the
n-word like a lot and it's like always
like a lot of caucasians at my show yeah
like do y'all still go by caucasians or
just white
i don't hear people say that no more
like
i'm caucasian no i'm white like i'm
black we don't say african-americans
yeah i've never been like hello i'm a
caucasian
one personality
caucasian section please
that sounded like i wanted to be a part
from everybody that is not what i meant
don't back away people make mistakes
people are like he's a racist i just
i am not a racist
yeah i have a song
so sorry yeah good reset
good reset you have a song where you say
the n word about yeah and i usually stop
and now because all the white people
would be scared to say it and i
make them say the hook over and
everybody says
they think like i'm just this super
down to earth dude it's just like i just
want you to say it
[Laughter]
for the release yeah like i'm just like
i mean just say it it's 2013. i don't
really care
no
everybody saw django man cool i saw
django
the one where he gets unchained
again ever since i made that inadvertent
comment they're like watch this fella
[Music]